200 years ago it took 12 days to send a letter from New York to London
And 150 years ago the first Telegraph cable was connected across the Atlantic from the Queen of England to the President of the United States
17 hours.
85 years ago, telephones became common household appliances
Thirty years ago, the first mobile phone that weighed a kilo was invented
It took 10 hours to ship and make a call for 35 minutes and its price was about $ 4,000.
Twenty years ago, the first text message was sent
A "happy birthday"
Today, the number of people with mobile phones is greater than the number of chairs
With nearly 23 billion text messages sent each day.
But how do text messages work?
When the radio operates a station, it receives information transmitted via electromagnetic waves at a certain frequency
In this case radio waves are picked up. These waves often pass through the body without interacting with it at all
But it is of the same spectrum that we see as just a difference in the scientific perspective
Photons with a wavelength of 400 to 700 nanometers have the perfect energy to pass through the receptors in your eyes
The signals are transmitted to your brain and are later interpreted in different colors
But radio waves that have a wavelength between 100 nm to 100 km
It has much less energy and can not reach your eyes.
So they are invisible to us
Similarly to a radio, your mobile phone picks up signals from similar frequencies
But it can also transmit its radio waves again over a network at the same time
A network is a system of towers, antennas and transmitters that divide geographical spaces into cells
Thus the term 'cellular phone'
These cells determine which areas use any tower service, even though they interfere until your phone always stays in the service to connect
Do you feel that your phone's battery is running out of power faster than usual?
Phones send signals at higher levels indoors because of building materials and in areas with large spaces due to distance between transmitters
When moving at high speeds such as cars because of the continuous rapid movement between transmitters
Whenever someone sends you a message, their phone sends a radio signal with your phone's ID and phone with the message content
That message is picked up by the nearest tower, which turns radio waves into digital electric pulses
And transfers them to a network center called the Mobile Switch Center
If you are out of service or the phone is switched off, the message is stored in the mobile switch center for a short time until you are found by the network
The network then detects the tower closest to you and turns the signal to it
When you reach the tower closest to you, electronic pulses turn back into radio waves that the antenna in your phone can pick up
This gets all in seconds.
Interestingly, the traditional SMS rate reached its peak in 2011
Currently most people send messages via internet services
In fact, last year, Watsp outdid traditional text messaging as the biggest text message connector
Connecting 30 billion messages sent every day in the world
If you send these messages across the world, they are sent via a huge Internet cable that crosses the ocean floor
In fact 99% of all data on the Internet is sent via wires that cross the sea
What does the future of text messages look like?
We are currently in the fourth generation of mobile networks and are working on the fifth generation
It was predicted that body phone technology could be available around 2023
While a century ago it could have taken months to deliver a love letter
Maybe in a few years we will be able to send these messages as soon as you think about the person and let him know that we care for him
We follow the new human communication method in the video of emoji - emoticons - on the bottom
How they are often misunderstood and how you can use them appropriately. Check out the video from the link in the description box
And participated in the channel, for more scientific videos weekly